[Music]
you just broke my wrist by the way sorry
the show the show that's happening on
the 13th is going to be a really awesome
show
we're going to talk about my you know my
ex-wife
we'll talk about my fights my rape
convictions yeah we'll talk about that
you're going to really talk about
everything that's everything everything
because i was hoping to write that book
when i get in that book and stuff
let me just go always remember that um
it's going to be a chapter jesus reigns
supreme
i'm a muslim too but this is something
that i realized that jesus reigns
supreme because over my times when i
talk about my sex of paids and all that
stuff i don't care what religion the
girl was muslim buddha
um christian jewish they always said
jesus oh jesus lord jesus jesus holy god
please stop jesus lord help please no
[ __ ] you
you completely
you completely had me i thought
i thought you were sharing a religious
epiphany
and it's a vaudeville bit
god damn when you're in jesus no please
got me i don't know man i just um
ah
my wife is gonna kill me for this yeah
i fear your wife you know what is uh uh
i wanna talk about you have made this
transition that nobody would have seen
in the 80s the 90s
even uh
eight seven years ago nobody would have
seen this happen you have transitioned
into comedy people find you
very amusing very funny is that
surprising to you no i yeah you know why
because i think i'm pretty dark and
stuff
and um
it's we're so past that now i wouldn't
worry
okay
i just go for it now
you know what i'm curious about is
i brought up how people seem to like you
doing comedy i saw a funny or die video
that you made where you were playing
herman cain
and i thought
this is really funny and this is not the
mike tyson that i first started watching
in the 80s you know you're teaching a
different such a different guy now well
that was the dark side the outside gave
room to the light right you know as it
always does and it gave him to the light
and now i'm the light okay and i'm gonna
shine on the world on the 13th to the
18th
[Applause]